alright if you're coming from my last
video i've got even more interesting
breath of the wild tidbits that you
probably don't know about
we'll still have some of the basic bread
and butter tips but we're also going to
go more into the deep end this time
so prepare for some more glitches and
game development stuff
if you enjoy content like this give this
video a like i specialize in breath of
the wild and we'll be on top of the
newest zelda stuff pronto
alright let's get it going certain sides
of these common trees have roots that
can be backflipped off of to gain bullet
time quickly
just hold zl down hop forward then
backflip
this can be a nifty way to gain the
upper hand during a fight
the most common way to conduct shock
arrows while out and about is to stasis
a choo choo jelly then shoot it but you
can instead use a freshly killed frog
or lizard freeze them then shock them
this will also conduct shock arrows
also if you remember bomb chews from
past zelda games you can even send in
the animal towards an enemy encampment
and perform this as a makeshift electric
bomb chew
pretty nifty
tall trees with a pointed top can let
you rest up there to get your stamina
back
but it also lets you survey the area
with your scope and use the camera rune
including selfie mode no other rune
works unless you count
wind bombs i guess
when a twilight or light arrow is fired
the arrow usually disappears upon
striking an object
but certain rock hard objects cause it
to ricochet off
and you can actually see the arrow
bounce around oars are giant flints
so strike an oar with a piece of wood to
make a campfire and
take an even closer look
it's also possible for elemental arrows
to ricochet to the ground
by firing at a ferry elemental arrows
bounce off in different directions
shot girls can drop straight down and
shock opponents but the best use is fire
arrows in a grassy area
as the updrafts they create affect them
in real time and cause a chaotic
firestorm of ricocheting arrows
if you happen to pick up stall skull
while disguised you can use the r button
to kick attack and damage enemies freely
since the skull is technically a third
party and not your attack
you can use it to bully enemies to death
try doing the same trick on a lizalfos
though and they'll just
casually sidestep your kick cheeky
buggers
there's one apple tree with a beehive on
it in the lost woods that's technically
impossible to get to
we think maybe a dev put it there and
forgot about it but we'll never know
[Music]
small curbs such as the edge of towers
or the guard rails of sokala bridge
rapidly accelerate link when sliding
against it with a slick shield tony hawk
would be proud of your grinding skills
head to link's house then either burn or
spin attack his flower specifically on
his lawn
they act really weird
[Music]
an old trick is to swing a flame or
shock weapon then drop them mid-swing to
give them elemental properties on the
ground
called elemental ignition but an
ingenious use of this is to carefully
lay a trap on top of a metallic weapon
and sandwich it between a juicy piece of
meat it actually becomes a real working
mouse trap
did you know that the colosseum lynel
actually holds a torch that has a flame
blade skin
over it there's actually a couple ways
to show this but the easiest way is to
fire a fire arrow at the flame blade
just before the lynel disappears
then pick up the weapon while empty
handed to carry the live torch
this is called a torchized flame blade
but the best usage is to magnesis it and
burn enemies from a safe distance
if you pay close attention food that
gets frozen gets heavily increased
sliding properties
try not to freeze your meal on a
hillside or else your lunch might slide
away
although it can be pretty fun to watch
where they might end up
here's a photo from nintendo's hiring
website that displayed items used for
fully work during breath of the wild
development
this is my personal guess to which
sounds were which
here's also a short video that they
posted which showcased footstep
and equipment audio while walking
elemental key swings have small designs
on their wings matching to their element
such as glacier-like designs for ice
keys flames for fire keys
and lightning strikes for electric keys
by using the scope while on the master
cycle
then quickly placing a marker and
exiting the scope you will pivot the
bike and forcibly break things
you can break rocks push objects and
even knock down certain doors by
pivoting the bike
oh and break the bike itself
[Music]
there may be some small enemy animations
you may not have seen before in special
situations
such as guardian scouts breaking
cryoness blocks lionel's blowing away
bombs when they notice them
and a slightly different one when
they're surprised by them and wiz robes
summoning choo choos and keys
blizzard ross are not only massively
useful against packs of enemies but
they're also one of the best farming
tools in the game
especially making cliff farming a breeze
literally
decayed guardians usually have an
ancient part for you to grab
but there are a handful of special ones
in hyrule that carry
two for some reason
[Music]
if you're an extremely dedicated
treasure hunter you may at some point
have run into treasure chests on your
radar that are nowhere to be found
that's because they were unfortunately
misplaced during development to spawn
under the map
but through some glitches you can
actually still get to these hard to
reach chests underneath the map
[Music]
is it worth it for the reward at this
point not really but the fact that we
can get to these at all in such a weird
fashion
is the satisfaction that we wanted
[Music]
hopefully this will add to your arsenal
of even more things you didn't know
about breath of the wild
we continue to do more breath of the
wild covers to this day including expert
reacts and breakdown videos
and for everything else stay tuned right
here on gamespot